So Charlie Cox is back playing Daredevil in Spiderman.
Three Spider-Man trace, I think is how you pronounce that.
I'm pretty sure that's how you pronounce that. Look at this place.
It's all decorated for Halloween. I watch it. The chefs show on Netflix,
hopefully Netflix hasn't copyright strike this. Um,
that's amazing. That's absolutely amazing.
The trolley conscious coming back as Daredevil.
And here's the thing I'm glad that's happening because I'll be honest with you
guys. I know that like, there was a big match between FYGI and Jeff lobe,
uh, with Jeff lobe taking the TV side, 5g, taking the movie side,
there was kind of like, well, you know,
that's what we're going to refer to the Avengers movie is the event, you know,
and all that kind of stupid stuff. Um, I'm glad to see that,
like at least one is running the show and those characters are getting rolled
in, honestly, as excited as I am for Charlie Cox. Um,
I'm more excited for like Vincent D'Onofrio to return as the kingpin and Jon
Bernthal to come back as the Punisher,
because I don't think Vincent D'Onofrio died. Right? Kingpin didn't die in the,
uh, in the Netflix TV series. Did he like, I'm pretty sure he's still alive.
And Jon Bernthal was an amazing Punisher whose thing I would love to see John
Byrne fall,
come back as a Punisher to like face off against the new Avengers or something
like that. Ah, it'd be awesome.
But it was because the punishers had so many great moments,
like when he saved Spider-Man's life and civil war, well,
he saved her from being killed in the sewers of New York and then shows up on
the doorstep of captain America, like captain America's secret Avengers. And uh,
and, and.
It's like, dude, like, like Mack, you know, he comes busting and he's like Mac.
So they bring in some people to take care of Spider-Man and then you end up
finding out.
Captain America's allied himself with villains.
So like these villains come in and they're like,
we're here to help you capture the Punisher. Just sprays them down.
You know what I'm saying? Anything.
He just unloads on him and captain America freaks out.
He's like you murderer son of a bee and just starts attacking him.
And he's like, there were bad guys, cats. He just killed them on the spot.
Didn't even give him a chance to explain.
It was pretty. It was, it's not funny. It's hilarious.
It was hilarious. But, uh, but no,
I'm excited for Charlie Cox and that's the thing, man. Like the cast,
the casting just keeps coming out and out and out for Spiderman three, right?
Like, like what is it? We have, uh, what's his name coming back? Um, what, uh,
Alfred Molina, whatever his name is coming back from, uh,
from the old Spiderman to Sony movies to play doctor octopus. Again,
I want to see superior Spider-Man son. I want to see superior Spider-Man.
I want to see him take over the body of Peter Parker and like become the,
become like the superior Spider-Man and they become a better Spider-Man than
Peter Parker was superior. Spider-Man was amazing.
There's this point in the story? When Dr. Octopus,
when he's in possession of Peter Parker's body,
he goes to fight the scorpion and punches the bottom half of his jaw off.
And then he's like, Holy cow,
Spiderman has been pulling his punches all these years. It's the craziest thing.
It's one of the coolest things, but, uh, but no trolley Cox is Daredevil.
He was, he was incredible. Right?
Dare devil was obviously the standout show on Netflix. It was an amazing show.
Uh, I'm glad to see that it's coming back.
I'm glad to see the Charlie Cox is the character that we all love him for it.
Because if I'm being honest,
I can't really see anybody else besides Ben Affleck. Just kidding.
I can't see anybody else playing Daredevil besides Charlie conch at this point,
like it's just it's it's he just did that good of a job. Right?
Then you throw him in with like Tom Holland and you, you throw him in with,
with Molina and you throw him in with like, what is it?
We're getting Andrew Garfield and we're getting Toby Maguire.
Then the Spider-Man movies. I mean, this is kind of crazy, man.
Like I haven't no idea what all this means. I mean,
I assume that there's going to be some multi-vessel travel going on. Otherwise,
how do you explain their existence? Unless like, you know, Dr. Strange is like,
Hey man, count yourself. Lucky with your identity being out, count yourself.
Lucky here's a Spiderman you could have been. And then shows all my Tobey,
Maguire and Andrew Garfield, mental hall. I was like, Hmm.
No, it'd be.
But nonetheless, I'm very, very excited. I am very, very excited for, for,
for this whole revelation. Um, here's the thing.
And I've been telling people this for years and years and years,
I've been telling people this for a long, long time, people like,
like the Marvel cinematic universe, what we've seen is the tip of the iceberg.
Everything that's happened in the last six last 10 years and the Marvel
cinematic universe for all you book readers out there,
this is a 12 issue story for us, right? Like that's, that's what this is, right.
This is just a maxi series, right?
Maybe a little bit bigger if you want to throw in a few times and you can make
each individual's individual film, its own comic. So, okay.
Like a 22, 23 issue, long, long thing, right?
Like there are whole runs of characters that span hundreds of issues just to
give you guys perspective, right? Like digital,
civil war story was over 100 issues long.
Like just to give you guys perspective here, right?
At the same thing with like Avengers versus X-Men it was like 120 issues long.
It was crazy. The old annihilation, including the tire,
the thing was actually a little bit shorter.
Annihilation conquest was a lot bigger. Uh, but you know,
this is the tip of the iceberg.
Like Marvel has barely even begun to approach the possibility of
even thinking about the idea of getting into like the meat and potatoes of
everything they could do. But there's so much that little be another story.
What are you doing? What are you looking at? Look, look, my dog is dog star.
What are you doing? What do you want her? She's got an Ms. Piggy with her.
What do you want star?
I post on Instagram on my personal Instagram. I am Rob Jefferson.
I posted up there. She, uh, she drugged big,
dirty out of Mariah's office and was laying on it in the hallway. Right? Big,
big dirties. The name of the big Teddy bear. We have,
we were going through Walmart and I saw this giant Teddy bear that I wanted to
get Mariah. So I bought it and uh, and we, and I called it big dirty. So that's,
that's the name of it now? Big, dirty the Teddy bear.
But, uh.
But yeah, you know, this is, this is kind of, wow.
So just celebrate this monument.
Just a moment to celebrate this monument moment.
Um, some Encore rings again. Yes we are. But I've also got Merck.
I've also got like t-shirts and stuff like that. I've got four design for,
for rod por t-shirt design.
You'll find the t-shirts and the rod port rings down in the description. Um,
I want to,
I want to kind of put those on sale now so that if anybody orders them,
you can get them in time for Christmas. Some of you guys bought them for like,
you were buying them like two or three at a time. Right.
Buy them ones for like yourself and like your girlfriend or your girlfriend was
buying it for like herself and you or whatever the case was when people were,
was it somebody bought it for like their younger brother white.
So we had people, we were buying like two or three at a time. Uh, but last,
last time we did this, they, they sold out in two hours. So, um,
you gotta be fast because.
They're going to go quick. But anyway, got it.
Let's not just say all the people who were following the, the,
the store on Etsy, uh, because that's where they get sold.
So what are you doing? Why are you barking?
They get sold on Etsy and there are people who are following the store.
So as soon as they go live, they're immediately on there and they started,
they started buying them up. So you better be quick,
you better be super quick because it's going to be 20 of each size.
The same time we did last time. Same thing we did last time. Um,
there will also be a size 12 out this time around. So, uh, so yeah, it's,
it's kind of wild kind of crazy, uh, but very, very, very, very cool.
All these different castings that are going out now. Like it's, it's,
it's really wild. Like I'm, I'm very excited about this. So anyway, guys,
we're going ahead and wrap this video up. Uh, thank you guys for watching.
And I just want to say this. This is, it's a great time to be a comic book fan,
right? It's a great time to be a comic book fan. Now,
I guess all we're really waiting for here is venom to be rolled over into the
MCU.
I guess it's all we're really waiting for is venom to be brought over into the
Marvel cinematic universe. Uh,
and it's all just kind of coming together and as being cohesive, right? It's,
it's getting, getting more and more cohesive. So, uh,
high times ahead of us folks, I will say,
I think Spider-Man three is going to have massive ramifications for the future
of the MCU,
with different movies that we're going to see and all that kind of stuff.
I feel like it's going to have massive ramifications.
We're going to see a whole bunch of stuff coming out of there. Probably.
X-Men probably fantastic for some things like that.
I wouldn't be surprised if there's some throwaway scene where Peter Parker gets
an invitation to the future foundation and throws it away through your
foundation. Of course, is a fantastic four founded by Reed,
which are just like their own think tank kind of thing. Ah, it's cool. Right?
So I'm, I'm very, very excited. I am very, very hyped. Uh, this is huge news.
So.
I was going to go ahead and bring this video to an end and I will catch you all
later, Bruce.